I said earlier that the reason we needed
to put parenthesis around 3w + 12n, or the
total amount of money that Grant would
have gained from the orders that have now
been canceled, was because this is one sum
of money, we want to subtract the whole
thing, not just part of it. If we didn't
have parenthesis here then we would only
be subtracting the money that he would
have earned from the wipers that are now
canceled, but we would still be adding the
amount of money that he would have gotte
from the nozzle orders that are now
canceled. But we know that both of these
sets of orders have been cancelled, so we
need to make sure that both of them are
subtracted from the original sum of money.
So let's put those parentheses back.
However, I don't really want these
parentheses here in the end version of
this expression, so we need to get rid of
them somehow. Intuitively like I just
said, you want to subtract both this
quantity 3w the money from the cancelled
wiper orders and this quantity 12n the
money from the cancelled nozzle sales. So
we want to subtract both of them and if I
get rid of these parentheses I should just
be able to switch this plus sign to a
minus sign and have the expression that.
That I want. This makes sense. Here's our
original amount of money that Grant
would've earned from all of the orders
that he had. And then we take away both
the wipers that he's not selling anymore
and the nozzles he's not selling anymore.
That makes sense. Now the problem is
simple, you've done this so many times
before. You just need to rearrange the
order of the terms, so that like terms are
now. Next to each other and then simplify.
So, first we rearranged the order of the
terms so that w terms are next to each
other and the n terms are next to each
other and then we just add their
coefficients together and multiply it by
the proper variable. So 87-3 is 84 and the
variable there is w and 72-12 is 60 and
the variable there is n. So here's our
final answer. Answer, 84w + 60n. Awesome
job. That quiz had a bunch of steps in i
t, and some new material. So if you got it
even partially right, that's really great.